land is about
one woman's resilience in overcoming an
unfathomable
event that takes place in her life
and through the kindness of a stranger
has a new renewed sense of faith and
hope and it's about human resilience
in the beginning edie is very resistant
to letting
anything news about the outside world
the closeness that would be of norm
you know where you meet someone and
you start talking about your lives with
one another and they don't do that
in this movie and he respects that wish
of hers
when she just wants to keep it spare
and he is also a character who's very
spare with his words
so that chemistry between the two of
them
i wanted it to feel palpable even though
we didn't have
multiple scenes that were lengthy
dialogue scenes
i wanted you to feel that beautiful
connection
between them on this scene miguel comes
back once again to visit
edie when miguel brings this drawing
to edie it's um
it's a very important connection with
what happens in
miguel's life and
how that connects so it is life i think
it's important that edie understands
that miguel
is also
a real person that deserve you know
although she
might think he's an angel you know he
also
he has his own life and he's been
through his own
you know thoroughly and he's
basically saying goodbye you will be
gone for a while
it has been a very intense
type of encounter and it's always you
know
difficult to to know
if you're gonna see each other again if
you're going to see anyone in your life
again
so they have this very simple exchange
not a lot of words and
because of his compassion and empathy
and rescue of her
she is now in a rebirth stage of her
grief
and is ready to face
the pictures literally ready to face
them
because she hasn't been able to do so
for quite some time
so it's that's a moment of acceptance
and reflection at the same time
so
my niece elkie drew this
it's beautiful they always ask about my
hermit friend
who lives in the mountains i think they
think i'm making it up
she wants you to keep it well i'm going
to get something for elky
and give her something to prove i exist
so
hmm
uh i have to go away for a while
potter loves her here do you think you
could take him for me
sure when will i see you again
it's hard to tell this time stay here
boy
okay be good
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi buddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
one of the challenges of the film was
respecting the fact that the cabin and
wildlife and isolation was in fact
a character or a set of characters under
themselves because this film is so much
about quiet
and wilderness and open space so the
cabin's role
and especially as a bridge between
miguel and edie was the focus frankly of
our early efforts and
we had to get it right and i think what
we
what we set as a goal was to
keep it brutal and intact from an inside
and outside relationship standpoint
the props that are exchanged in that
scene were so so important because there
are so few
connections back to her chicago life and
relationships to their child drew
the boy that we never really see except
in a ghostly or flashback manner
so i've always found as a designer you
can always
none of us adults can replicate that
sort of magic
looseness uh and freedom that children's
drawings have
so um it was so special for me and my
kids frankly to see those drawings
because
i i routinely recruit my daughters to do
a lot of these drawings
because you just can't beat the um
the penmanship and the approach and the
abstraction that children use
when they do these kinds of things we
all talked very carefully with trevor
about
positioning of windows and direction
that would let light
into that place we were 8 000 feet up
and as trevor said we were going to make
a facsimile of this
cabin on a stage we decided
why would we want to you know discount
the views out
of these windows and why would robin
want to stand on a stage and be staring
at green screens when she could actually
stare um you know be involved
with the landscape on front of her face
the things that made the film most
difficult
to shoot i.e the elements in the weather
made the film better because you know we
could feel
we could feel the nature not only just
see it but it would affect how
she behaved i spent
practically every night of the shoot in
that cabin
i slept there often with the camera
and some lenses so that eve
if the crew was leaving early and the
sun was going down i could get some
spectacular virgin shots of the sun
set without a crew walking around
the thing that i get most from this
scene
is the lighting more so than the
composition it was something that i was
more conscious
about when constructing the scene with
robin they meet
outside in a sunny day again this man is
bringing her light
and hope in the sunshine he gives her
this drawing
and she decides that she wants to repay
him so she goes inside and she goes to a
memory
that she's kept locked up in secret
something too painful for her
to to face for a long time and
she takes this drawing out she's backlit
her face is in shadow and the moment she
opens the drawing
the light that is coming from the back
hits the drawing itself and
quite practically and symbolically and
literally
the light bounces off of that piece of
paper and lights her face so
in essence this memory instead of
bringing her pain actually brings her
hope and light
and joy
[Music]
with that she wants to gift it to him
the return of the kind of light and
hope and joy that he's given her
i feel that this is an important scene
because
you go through phases
humans go through phases of different
emotions
and the fact that she is not able
to
you know visually look at photographs
of her past she's not ready
and when i say phases i mean that very
thing
you know there are there is a phase at
some point when you are ready to move to
the next phase
i i believe that uh there are
there are angels in our you know life
that we encounter
at certain points that help us
transit through difficult times
sometimes we don't even know that they
were around sometimes we're not even
aware
of their presence and sometimes
they are very present and very
you know tangible like miguel
in it is life he he can be called
an angel because he
is willing to help
without asking anything in return
without even asking any questions
he doesn't need to know anything about
edie
he only knows that she needs help and
he's there
and as he says you know she wasn't on my
path
it's a big sign that
it was my turn in life my
it was it was uh up to me to help this
human being
i had the opportunity on this movie to
talk to
some very experienced psychologists and
psychiatrists who deal
with trauma and i really wanted to
understand
the varying degrees of it and how does
one
come out on the other side through these
characters
you understand that you can come back
from the deepest pain in life that you
could ever imagine experiencing
if you are lucky to find somebody else
and the way you find somebody else to
help you is to be open
for that help it's open to to that you
know opportunity
those type of stories are so much needed
and not only
nowadays but uh
as artists you know it's important that
we tell this
this type of story in the scene where
miguel is given the drawing by edie
um it's just a returned
gesture you know his
his gift to her is from his niece and
that's basically
saying to her my family
they want to know you they want to know
who my friend is
um and it's a welcoming
and she does the same in return she's
giving him a piece of her life without
having to say it
[Music]
and that's a trust
that she has in that man and
a beautiful human connection that that
she found
that allowed her to want to live again
[Music]
you